[Music]
so there's a man okay
in chile chile yep santiago capital
santiago
san diego
[Laughter]
mint chocolates holy [ __ ] that guy is
from chile it's a really weird shaped
country though yeah it is it's strange
oh it's like a chili it's like italy
that boot thing i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's like a chip but imagine imagine you
can go from one side to the other in 10
minutes but then the other way it's like
20 hours
do you even [ __ ] play with chopsticks
for like an hour dog
such a landman
who is accidentally paid
330 times his salary oh
resigns then vanished of course you
stole my article you piece of [ __ ]
you have this
this is an awesome day it's gonna be all
steve dave hick
but you [ __ ] ruined it dude my bad
this is gonna be the all-steep day daily
double [ __ ]
should i take his house should we talk
about something else you're fine
i'll get over it i'll get over it all
right cool
this is all ant day
so welcome to all ant day okay dude
anthony has no daily doubles
[Laughter]
c
just came out
is this the daily double this is he just
made the sound effects
it's just they have the button the
button you stab it no you don't gotta
look for it just do the article bro it's
a [ __ ] payday all right okay
300 times the normal amount how much was
he supposed to get people bringing it
back bart you are the most responsible
person here and it makes me [ __ ] pain
to know that
he watches the post
that was like a natural move for me he
doesn't watch the instrument yeah it was
good all right so a chilean man
was accidentally paid 330 times his
salary he resigns and he vanishes right
unnamed worker at consorcio industrial
de alimentos
which makes cold cuts aka joe's favorite
[ __ ] sandwich from subway
normally receives a paycheck of roughly
500 000 chilean pesos which is about
550 dollars
555 direct deposit to his account
in his most recent pay period on may
30th
a screw up in the company's hr
department resulted in him getting a
check for
in pesos 165
million 398
851
chilean pages
i would wait for that to 5x before i
take the money and run
you're right yeah that's not enough
if i get another 5x
that's what i think
in
in america is five thousand dollars
a little bit more a hundred and eighty
three thousand five minutes a lot of
money that's probably retirement money
right there that's a lot of money i
vanished too
[ __ ] but also here's the other half of
it though uh [ __ ] if you run away
like they're gonna be looking for you
they obviously know who the [ __ ] did
this all you have to do is drive 20
minutes you're out of the country ah and
you're gone
out of your direct deposit account
[ __ ] are you talking about argentina
by that bro guess what you get to go to
their [ __ ] spirit halloween store buy
whatever the [ __ ] you want you have
disguises for generations that's your
first stop after the heist of ascension
of course it is you're going like all
right
fake eyebrows come on dude you're in
forget it i got the screen mask on
i'm wearing i'm holding like a [ __ ]
no one will no one will find it
oh the screen that had the pup
my coach jersey with a woo hat
and i'm good you remember the screen
mask i had a pump in your pocket were
you the blood yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
these are the coolest kids look crazy
and then and you hear me and i'm like
her older and i squeeze it and the blood
comes
so bad wrong person we're looking for
steve green oh yeah no no that's not me
hey you should buy wu though check it
out
hey indianapolis let's [ __ ] go to you
you're looking for stephen sorry i'm mr
nikki limo that's me dude very different
wait you'll you'll see
so this guy
takes the matter what you say like
italian this guy
so this guy he takes a matter to a
manager right
to report his overpayment which is when
the hr error is discovered for the first
time
the company then told him to go to his
bank to initiate the return of the money
no way he promised to go there the next
day and that's exactly what he did
what he didn't do however was return the
money
after three days of calls and whatsapp
messages
the company got a message from a lawyer
representing the worker
offering his resignation
since then no one at the company has
heard from the worker the company has
filed a complaint charging the worker
with misappropriation of funds in hopes
of recovering some of the lost money but
so far there have been no arrests
because he drove 10 minutes and went out
of her girl he's out bro this is the key
to the life right here you just [ __ ]
lawyer up i was going to slow your run
he must have some kind of [ __ ] case
if he can hire a lawyer though it's
important because bart kind of commented
on this earlier about how much that
actually is in chile specifically right
so while the windfall like that would be
huge in any country even america to get
like 330 times your salary
it's
especially notable in chile where the
average worker takes home roughly 1 000
us dollars a month wow so imagine this
guy got in the average chilean entire
country he had like 183 months worth of
salary in one [ __ ]
so his 500 was like his month's payment
550 555 was his average monthly salary
that he was supposed to receive 555
dollars he got 180 grand what would you
guys do you work at subway i'd buy a
plane
there it is
hey this is joe's easy i'm listening
he got so excited bro i'm a [ __ ] i'm in
i call my wife
and i say
hey baby there's a lot of big blinds
let's go you know it's not a big one
you're in the wsop for the next [ __ ]
180 years your bankrolled your bankroll
papa steve got you worried about it
countries are also different right
because you're like i could get away
with a lot of [ __ ] over here yeah you
gotta pay off everybody but the
government might find you get away with
i don't know murder how about this i buy
one board ape
and then i watch it go to zero
[Laughter]
overnight
overnight because of a medium post about
racism
my [ __ ] future my entity future is
that the whole thing where they were
saying that the board ape guy is like a
nazi yeah yeah hidden nazi symbols it's
all it took that's crazy like a house of
cards that's why it's crumbly yeah bro
for real not fresh
also low liquidity obviously like bear
market but that was the big like little
that's the catalyst obviously bear
market everything crumbled but the point
is oh yeah
well no that that really did like pull a
lot of value
how how like what's the percentage that
it dropped like value bro you could have
sold it it dropped like
200 g's
185 000 up for a jpeg yeah like two
months ago and now how much is it now
it's over how much though i don't even
know it's so bad
is it one each though
uh yeah yeah it's one eight but you know
how much one heath is right now it's
like eleven hundred dollars
i mean bro all the way to can you
believe
can you believe these jpegs
didn't hold their values
yeah that's [ __ ] nice crazy you
everyone thought that they were going to
hold value forever so the creator's a
[ __ ] nazi
that's all it takes i don't know is he
is he actually a nazi no no
i don't know enough to know i just i'm
telling you what everyone's saying and
so that's all it takes sometimes wow
that's crazy imagine he is he's just
sitting there just like they found my
plan
they found out
oh no it's the board yacht club it's a
failure the second coming of the third
rank
did anyone see this coming it wasn't the
bear market
that got to me
i'm sorry i've been drinking and he's
funny you enjoyed the clip that was good
the cooks are really good i i don't if
you if you're a subway worker in chile
and this opportunity the sandwich place
you'd probably run would you would you
do the same [ __ ] if i was a subway
worker i would make an
outside house
myself i give the money back
wow if you work for subway there was no
[ __ ] country or ultimate dimension
where joe gives the money back i swear
to god i'm honorable bullsh okay let's
say on your youtube channel
on your vlog channel your adsense
randomly three million dollars i take
the money
they tell you to give it back
but subway
he's like somebody needs this money i'm
honorable i'll take it
i'm so afraid of daddy google
daddy google is very scary don't always
get their money back because chili
government and maybe you can like pay
him off or run away daddy google though
they're all over the world
like there's no place in the world where
they don't they can't see or find you
okay so what if adsense gives you a [ __ ]
ton of money on accident you take that
money
you buy google ads with it for your
business
and they go man i guess you're giving it
back watch the way they recycle it
if they're not going to come after me
yeah you know what i do
i go to duckduckgo and then guess what i
do what the [ __ ] is duckduckgo you don't
know what doctor it's the [ __ ]
browser for porno dogs it's the browser
for security yeah exactly oh sorry
i thought i want the truth let me tell
you something if you want to try to find
out what something is about
and then you don't ever find out what it
is use duckduckgo i see because it's a
real bad search engine but it has good
it has a good idea behind it but a real
bad search engine really really bad
execution i end up getting duckduckgo
and then typing google.com and then i
start
that's what i do it doesn't even direct
you to google either it like since you
did
that's how the internet's done you
literally i can't even find my own
twitter with it i'm like how was this i
mean how did you guys [ __ ] pull up
search results that from like
seven years ago nobody's looking for
this one
how can't you find it
[Music]
[Music]
you